hi there today we'll look at singen
learning a generative model from a
single natural image by tomorrow Tom
Tully deco and Tamara mckylie so this
paper as it says it's dealing with
learning and generative model from just
one image and this kind of needs to be
stressed because most generative model
even if they produce single image
samples they're kind of trained on a
large image database beforehand to kind
of learn what a what an image is but
this algorithm really starts out clean
slate right algorithm starts out with
nothing and then you give it this one
single training image and from that it
can then generate all of these things
all right without ever having seen any
other images during training and the
second row is simply a second example
where you start clean slate input this
image and then produce this and you can
see there's quite a bit of variety in
the samples you produce from this image
so basically the task is if you're just
given one image learn something about
the distribution and this paper
specifically deals with patch
distributions at different scales so
this could be learn about you know the
distribution of this grass to to sky
here so learn about the individual birds
and so on and then at lower scales learn
about how the border of this grass looks
right so you can the generative model
learns ah there's you know there's
always kind of grass at the bottom in
where there's just one image at the
largest-scale but then at lower scales
sometimes the border looks that's like a
sharp corner and sometimes the border is
relatively flat like here so it can vary
up those things and it can make it can
make the border different as also the
birds it kind of learns how the
individual birds look and how they're
distributed and they're therefore it can
change that you see there's quite a bit
of variety
here you can also change the aspect
ratio and you can actually do much more
much weirder things with it for example
here are some examples of applications
first there is paint to image so these
are different tasks here so the top row
is always the training image this is the
single image you give the algorithm and
then you have a row of input and then
this is what the algorithm outputs so in
paint the image you input the training
image and you input a you can do this in
ms paint or something kind of the way
you want the the image to look right so
what you want the algorithm to do is
take the style you take you want it to
take the style of this image and put it
into the form of that image and it will
it produces this looks pretty good in
editing you can tell the algorithm all
right I want this I want this tower to
go lower down right I want this house to
be more wide so you'll get an image like
this and you can see there are clear
kind of contours here and here that are
not nice and also the houses you know
pixel stretched and so on so this this
algorithm this generative algorithm can
produce this image from it which looks
much better here around the borders and
kind of fills in missing windows too
much of course the patch statistics that
it sees in this top image right you
always have to think that this all this
algorithm sees is the topmost image to
learn from harmonisation is a task where
you have an input image and then you
like copy/paste some object in it and
what it does is it will kind of adjust
the patch statistics of that object to
the surrounding image and
super-resolution finally finally we get
what every single action movie the just
that NSA can do it's like ah here is the
security camera footage zoom in
enhance like
yeah so I doubt that that you know
hidden number plates here pixel is
number plates all of a sudden can become
readable and identifiable but still this
this is very cool and lastly you can do
animation from this as you can guess I
guess it's not a solid a movie alright
let's look at how they do all of this
kind of stuff all of this is the same
model that can be tasked to do these
different things through various probing
at its essence it's this multi scale gun
and the gun is trained to have a series
of generators and a series of
discriminators and you always train them
one by one so first you train the lowest
resolution and then you keep it fixed
and then train the next resolution and
so on until you're at the highest
resolution so in each layer so at the
bottom layer we simply feed in I simply
feed in noise to a generator of again
and the generator generates an image all
right now you take this image and you
take a down sampled version of your
training image remember you just have
one training image you take a down
sampled version of that and you let the
discriminator decide which one is real
which one's fake and they trained a
generator to fool the discriminator as
much as possible now if you were to do
this with the entire image of course the
generator would simply learn to
reproduce the original image so that's
no good so what you what this paper does
more is that the discriminator actually
doesn't work on the entire image but
just on patches of the image right and
that's that's too so that the basically
can't memorize the entire image so the
discriminator will pick these patches
these overlapping patches basically you
can imagine it's something like this
overlapping patches
it will try to decide for each one is
this patch real or is this patch fake
right so the generator produces the
entire image right this is what that
generator produces the entire image but
the discriminator can only see the image
in patches in overlapping patches and
that's what makes this paper kind of
work otherwise the they would just
remember the the single training image
right because you only have one training
image you kind of need a some variety so
this is at the lowest scale right you
remember you input the noise and the
lowest scale in this example is for
example 25 by 25 pixel you scale down
you scale down your original image here
also to 25 by 25 and then you let the
discriminator decide
so once you've trained this once you've
trained this generator to make very good
25 by 25 pixel images that in this patch
way fool the discriminator you keep it
fixed for the next stage what you want
to do is you always want to go through
this layer first
so forget this discriminator now we've
retrained this stage right keep this
generator fixed input noise output
whatever the generator produces then
take this up scale it's for example
multiply each side by 2 - 50 by 50
pixels in put this together with some
new noise into the next stage generator
and then the same as before this
generator produces an image you scale
down your original image you scale it
down to now 50 by 50 pixels and you let
the discriminator decide again in
patches
now since the discriminator patches are
always the same size but we scale down
the image less and less the effective
patch size of the discriminator becomes
much lower so now this discriminator
only sees the image in patches like
so right and also the the generated
image that comes in here it also always
also sees in these patterns it tries to
decide are these patches from real or
from fake images so you can see that the
lowest layer here this layer is trained
to kind of get the coarse grained
structure of the of the image
alright the discriminator will will kind
of see very large patches and it so the
generator must match the kind of
large-scale structure if these patches
won't be very very high-resolution
because we down scaled image but they
will be large across the image so the
generator must match the coarse low
resolution stuff in the image but as you
go up the layers up and up the layers
your discriminator sees less and less of
the picture at once excuse me it sees
less and less of the picture at once and
so the this discriminator here in the
topmost layer can only concentrate on
very small patches and therefore this
generator will only have to produce
things that look real at a very very
small scale right so uh in essence you
have this series of generators trained
that each one is tasked with basically
modeling details at a finer and finer
scale until you come to the last final
scale but then each input of the each
one is the output of the last one so
basically you take whatever the last one
has produced and the last one is really
good at doing coarser grain things and
you add to it your details of this level
and this will in the end give you a very
realistic image that matches at every
level of resolution matches the kind of
statistics that patch statistics of this
real image so that's the that's the
whole the whole point kind of of this of
this thing to have this series of
generators one after the other each one
adds their own details at its own scale
and and this works super well apparently
so each generator is just built like
this it takes the not some noise and the
image of the lower scale it adds them
sorry for these artifacts it puts it
through five convolutional layers and
then simply combines it with the input
right and this will produce this image
at this scale that's that's each layer
it's just five common layers and since
they're fully convolutional you can
actually change the aspect ratio at
inference time you can change the the
resolution and so on it's it seems it
seems pretty neat
of course from experience I can tell you
that this probably didn't work at the
first try and there is a lot of work
even though it seems pretty easy you
know keep that in mind
so for training this there are actually
two different losses first of all you
have what's called the adversarial loss
and the adversarial loss is your classic
gaen loss right where the generator
tries to tries to fool the discriminator
and the discriminator tries to catch the
generator but then also you have a
reconstruction loss and the
reconstruction loss specifically deals
at each layer at each layer you train
the generator to reconstruct the
original image when you put in a zero
noise except that the lowest layer but
essentially what you want to do is you
want to say well when when I don't input
any noise then please reconstruct the
original image and that seems to be
important for this for the set up to
include this noise so that the
generative model is basically able to
reconsider
the original image as a whole right so
these two losses are combined to form
the training objective and again this is
not trained on data set it is trained on
a single each on a single image and the
the productions are pretty cool so again
here are more samples from just the
single training images at the left side
and then you have random samples from
the single image you can do things like
super resolution where this picture has
been super resolute 'add to that picture
and I like that they investigate the
effects of kind of their setup so they
ask okay what happens if we just have a
two basically two different scales of in
this in this scaling setup then you see
the kind of patch statistics will be
very very fine-grained and it won't
match the any sort of coarse grain
structure if you have very many scales
right the more scale you have better
basically they're more different scales
you capture even more interesting is I
find is what if so at this layer where
we have GGG right you scale up scale up
scale up and so on what you could do is
you could not start start here but you
say okay scrap this layer what we
actually do is we take the original
image and we scale it down and we input
that into here instead of inputting the
output from the lower layer so basically
you start at let's say the ground truth
and that effect is is shown here if used
so if you if you start at the lowest
layer in this particular example you see
that the sometimes there are there are
weird things but what you can do is
start at a let's say an intermediate
layer with the original image and then
the variety you get because you kind of
keep the coarse grain structure the same
the right you get will only be
in there right we said there are
different layers and but you now
eliminate these two layers and replace
them with the original images at the
scale so the variety you get will only
be from these finer grained lower
resolution patches things so for example
as you can see here the zebra samples
now differ in how exactly their stripes
are manifested and it seems this seems
pretty cool so you have kind of a handle
on how fine-grained you want your
details or your changes to be and they
do a bunch of more experiments where you
can do a lot of kind of playful things
with this thing there is code available
for example here you can see editing
again as an example where they compare
also with content aware move which i
think is implemented in photoshop and
paint harmonization as we saw before so
all of these kind of things are very
playful are very cool and I encourage
you to check out this paper and the code
it seems pretty easy I have a remark
though this this again is only learned
from a single image and that's the kind
of cool part but it should be possible
to combine this with some sort of
approach over a a dataset like if if I
have a model that is really good at a
single image right producing something
that looks like a single image I should
be able to combine it with a model that
has been learned from a database all
right it's kind of like a Bayesian
approach where you say okay I want to
produce the best image so I want to
maximize the probability of this image
given the other image right but then you
can also say aha but that's that's kind
of proportional to J given I times
P of I read you know Bayes rule and it
seems that this paper is dealing mostly
we're kind of maximizing the likelihood
of the output while you could probably
combine it with some sort of prior over
natural images and come up with an even
better model of course then you need an
actual database of images and training
procedure and you need to wait to
combine these two models so maybe that's
a bit of a challenge
anyway cool paper check it out bye bye